-Welcome back, everybody!
It is time to play
"Can You Feel It?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Can You Feel It ♪
-But I'm gonna need some help.
Her movie "Puss In Boots:
The Last Wish"
opens in theaters December 21st.
Please welcome
Salma Hayek Pinault!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, come on!
Stop it. Mwah!
-Hi, guys!
-Mwah!
-Come on.
-Hello!
-That's what I'm talking about.
Yes!
-Yes!
-Alright, now...
-Let's go!
-I'm so happy you're here.
And thank you for playing
this game.
Here's how it works --
we're gonna have a number
of mystery objects brought out
to us, in front of us.
Our job is to guess
what each one is.
The catch is that we have to
figure it out by touch alone.
You cannot see it.
You ready for this?
[ Laughter ]
Are you scared?
-I'm going over
the -- the rules.
-Okay, yeah, yeah.
Just -- just, you feel it.
And whatever you feel,
you guess what it is.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Salma, since I'm the host,
I'll go first.
-Yes, yes.
-No! What?!
No, normally, it's,
"I'm the host, you go first."
-Ladies first.
-Let's get our first object.
Okay, I have 30 seconds...
[ Laughter ]
...to identify...
-Can I...?
-You can look at it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Shouts ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Aaaah!
-Come on, Jimmy.
You can do this.
-I know, I know, I understand.
I hate this so much.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
[ Inhaling sharply ]
Yo! Stop. Stop.
Questlove, stop it.
-It moves.
-No!
What do you mean it moves?
-Come on, come on.
You're running out of time.
-I know, I know.
-Go in there.
[ Scattered screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Shouts ]
-Oh, Elf on the Shelf!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why is it moving?
They don't move.
They don't --
Why is that moving?
They don't normally move.
-That was so easy.
That was so easy.
-That's -- that is ridiculous.
They don't normally move.
This is -- You're -- That's --
Whoever's in trouble
is in trouble.
That's -- that's the first time
I think I ever guessed one.
-No, they move.
That's the whole point.
They move from place to place.
-I know, but we --
-Oh, that's true.
They do. They fly.
-No?
-Yes, yes.
Salma, here we go.
This is for you.
It should be just as nice
as an Elf on the Shelf.
-Okay.
-Yeah, it's very easy.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Okay.
-Mmph!
Wait, why are you so --
what are you doing?
[ Laughter ]
What is wrong with you?
What are you --
You're just throwing it around.
What are you doing?
You just -- you can't...
[ Laughter ]
-Music box.
-Yes, it's a music box.
[ Bell dinging ]
Yeah, very good.
-Is it? Is it?
-What's wrong with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Bring it on.
Is it a music box?
-Is there scarier ones?
Is there scarier ones
for Salma?
-I broke it.
-I feel like we might have to
switch up the order here
to make sure, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
Give me something
more challenging.
-Yes, you just went right in
there and threw it around.
There's a poor little
ice skater there.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here we go.
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Nah, nothing.
-Nothing?
-Piece of cake.
You can get this.
-Nothing.
-Dig in there.
Dig in there, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Audience cheering ]
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Screaming ]
-What is it?
You're running out of time.
What is it?
-I'm bleeding, I'm bleeding!
[ Laughter ]
[ Screaming ]
Ketchup?
Sriracha?
-You're almost there.
-Cocktail sauce?
Shrimp?
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do we have, like, a bucket,
just in case?
-Now smell your finger.
-No, I'm not -- I'm not --
[ Laughter ]
-You did touch that shrimp.
-What's wrong with you?
I'm not playing --
that's a different game.
I'm not playing that.
[ Laughter ]
Now look, here's...
Salma, you're up right now.
Here.
-Okay.
-Just gonna save --
-Oh, there's a skater.
-There's a skater from when
you destroyed that last one.
Yeah, here you go.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Let me see.
♪ Ba-ba-dah ba-dah ♪
Oh, no! Hold on a second!
No, wait -- No, that's the --
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-It's a cake with a...
brush...
Oh, my God.
-Oh, my God.
What are you doing?
That was it.
-This is disgusting.
-How did I get --?
[ Bell dinging ]
-This is a disas--
What are you...?
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-"A piece of cake with a brush."
What's going...
-I got it right.
-No, you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?!
-Yeah, it's a cake with a brush.
I smelled it.
This is cake.
-Is that what that is?
A toothbrush with icing on it?
-It's the top of the cake.
-Here, wipe this off.
-Ay, this is toothpaste?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Here, here. Take this.
Sorry. Salma, I'm sorry.
-It's King Kong's toothbrush,
because that's not the normal...
-[ Laughs ]
King Kong's toothbrush.
Oh, Salma, get ready.
This is time for the final --
-But I got the brush part.
-Yeah, the judges said that --
-Do I get half a point?
-Yeah, yeah, you got half.
[ Bell dings ]
-We're both gonna get
the same item here, okay?
And the first person to guess it
wins all the points on this one.
-Okay.
-Yes, but -- wait.
-I'm listening.
I'm paying attention.
-Okay.
-I'm still cleaning the nails.
-You're still cleaning
your nails?
Alright, ready?
We can do this.
-Okay.
-Do you want to go on this side
and I'll go from that side?
-No, no.
[ Audience exclaims ]
-It's moving.
Did you move it?
♪♪
[ Audience oohs ]
Oh, oh! Hey!
That's your hand!
-It's a hand, for sure.
-Oh, my God. It is a hand.
There's someone in there.
[ Bell dinging ]
Oh, my God. Watch out.
Watch out. Oh, my God.
Thing! It is...
Wow, sorry about that.
-Oh, that was so easy.
-He's very strong.
It is Thing from --
-Give me a five.
-They can't see.
...Addam's Family.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are so...
Nothing scares you.
Salma Hayek Pinault,
everybody -- the champ!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Unbelievable, you are so good.
We'll be right back with more
Salma after the break.
Let's get that out of your nails
right there.
-♪ I walk across this world
that's deceptive ♪
♪ Beats are perfected,
the hood is infested ♪